amérique du sud côte pacifique pérou à
la frontière de la bolivie cette fois ou
à 4000 mètres d'altitude on découvre une
véritable mer intérieure
c'est le lac titicaca et rivages de ce
lac sont peuvent et par les indiens
aymaras qui à l'époque
gates avait été conquis et soumis paris
quetchua lesquels peuple la plus grande
partie du groupe
une petite partie des nra suivi de la
pêche qui pratiquent sur le curieuse
barque en roseau une fameuse balsa de
tortora plus encore que les autres aux
indiens si cela est possible les mrh
raffolent de fès qui leur permettent
d'échapper à la tristesse sans espoir de
leur existence
ces fêtes durent plusieurs jours et
débute par de grands marchés où les
indiens trouve à se restaurer après leur
longue marche et surtout la pacotille
on trouve aussi la pacotille que la
civilisation occidentale leur a donné
l'habitude d'utiliser là entre autres
il trouve les colorants qui leur
permettent de teindre eux mêmes leurs
vêtements qu'ils fabriquent encore
aujourd'hui entièrement à la main
mais ces faits et ces marchés sont un
véritable pactole pour les diseurs de
bonne aventure
en voici un de ces diseurs de bonne
aventure il a eu une idée ingénieuse de
faire tirer ladite bonaventure par des
pertes elles mêmes par des sages
théoriquement le pérou est un pays
catholique c'est d'ailleurs pour
évangéliser ces populations qu'il fût
conti mais la religion du christ dans se
mélangeant au culte du soleil a donné un
assez curieux cocktail pour la plupart
des indiens la vierge n'est qu'une sorte
de déesse donc vous promène les ferries
monumentale à l'occasion de chaque fait
ces processions et le fils qui les
précèdent attire une foule considérable
à cette occasion les femmes des rares
indien enrichi dans le commerce ou dans
la tour même quelques-uns exhibe des
toilettes de soirée spectaculaire et
même fastueuse
on
l'intérieur du pérou est un pays presque
entièrement indien mais il a été
profondément marqué par la culture et
les traditions espagnoles
l'une de celles-ci est la coutume des
corridas il n'y a pas de fête sans
combat taureau mais il s'agit le corrida
pour rire vous allez le voir ces
corridas ne comporte pas de mise à mort
et d'ailleurs personne ne les prend très
très osé me voilà donc je prépare
il a cependant kempen se fasse encore
nés dans un coin mais en général les
taureaux ne sont ni très lourd ni très
brave les parfumeurs jamais bien
longtemps car lorsque ce n'est pas le
taureau qui s'est enfui mon dieu bossu
le toréador
tout ça et vous le voyez ici peu sérieux
que des gens commencent à danser dans
l'arène avant même que la cour se soit
terminée alors juger vous même
ses feuilles dures 80 jours et comporte
toujours un grand défilé en costumes
ceux ci sont très beaux et très ancien
il date de l'époque coloniale ou un flot
de richesse coulé sur le pv ils sont
d'ailleurs porté par de jeunes métis
propriétaires terriens descendants plus
ou moins directe des conquistadors
espagnols les exhibe sur toutes les
pièces d'argenterie en leur possession
les plats et même écarteurs
un concours de danse folklorique fait
aussi partie des traditions et des
délégations viennent parfois de fort
loin pour lui parce qu'ils sont faits
ces danses et costumes ont un caractère
symbolique aujourd'hui difficile à
déchiffrer par l'ensemble ils veulent me
mets ou ridiculisés des événements ou
des coutumes de l'époque coloniale
oui
le fréteur fouetter ou quelque chose de
semblable
à
après comment savez-vous table fait des
indiens ceux qui vivent dans des huttes
misérables et ne mange pas souvent alors
fait pour venir jusqu'ici ils ont
parfois marcher pendant des jours et
laure ici sont des images un petit peu
particulière vous les voyez arriver ces
indiens ils sont tous déjà à moitié ils
se répondent dans les rues du village en
bordure lente et tourbillonnante au son
d'une musique désespérément monotone à
force d'être toujours la même il
tournoie sur place inlassablement pour
les jours je dénonce il arrive ainsi à
atteindre une sorte d'extase qu'ils
recherchent avec l'énergie du désespoir
l'eau-de-vie extraits des déchets de la
canne à sucre la vidange en tête coule à
flots les jours de fête les indiens en
font une consommation absolument
fantastique pour filmer ces images
lionel terray a dû cacher sa caméra
parce qu'on lançait le pirée
les indiens boivent qui a sombré dans le
coma et inc et la fête ne se calmera que
vers le milieu de la nuit lorsque tous
ou presque seront tombés interrives aux
morts et pendant ce temps les femmes
gardent dans leur dos leurs enfants elle
les garde en toute circonstance que ce
soit pour danser pour bois pour manger
pour dormir
ces images peuvent peut-être paraître
cruel mais elles existent elles sont la
réalité
peut-être ça qui motive beaucoup de
choses pour éviter ces indiens je m en 7
étapes
c'est leur compte
mais tandis que se déroule cette orgie
abominable dans une autre partie du
village une fête plus raffiné a lieu
c'est la fête des colosses les métis
propriétaires terriens
ceux qui tiennent dans leurs mains
l'avenir du pérou